for coming today baller where the
presidential inauguration committee has
asked us to declare
a national day of unity and remembrance
and ask communities around the country
to remember and honor all of those who
have been lost during this pandemic
in some ways we feel that clark county
has suffered a little bit harder because
our economy we've lost our economy and
we lost
so many close to us as you all remember
it was march 15th that daniel scully
passed away
becoming las vegas's very first victim
of cobit 19.
10 months later here we are and i don't
think that any of us thought that we
were going to be
here 10 minutes later but i do know that
we have worked hard we will continue to
work hard as a community
to help us get through this as of this
week
a little over 2 800 people
have perished from the effects of coven
19.
those people are our neighbors our
friends
our community members mothers fathers
grandparents of so many and so we want
to really take this time
and to honor what was sacrificed
during covet 19 in our own community
each time that somebody passes more and
more of us know
who those folks are and it really leaves
a hole within
our hearts so we don't ever want to
forget
what we're doing today is very important
we are honoring those
that have really succumbed to the
disease that all of us have
come to know and understand a lot better
the road leading to this point has not
been easy
but i can tell you there's a lot of
optimism out there now that we have a
vaccine
now that we're working hard to ensure
that folks are getting the vaccine as
soon as possible
there's a light at the end of the tunnel
that we will
through this so in a few minutes we'll
be turning on these lights
of the clark county to remember the
clark county
victims of this pandemic and it's for
them
that i ask everybody within our
community we're one community one las
vegas
one clark county when nevada and one
united states of
america and i ask that all of us really
take a moment and honor all of those
as we turn on these lights we want to
remind people
where we bend where we will go in the
future
and just remember that somebody's family
is appreciative of what we are doing as
a community
so with that i'm going to invite my good
colleague
commissioner gibson up to say a few
words as well
thank you commissioner kirkpatrick
this is the first official day of
remembrance
of those who have passed on as a
consequence of the
of the covid pandemic
there have been as was indicated just
here in las vegas the greater las vegas
area and clark county
2873 who have died
as a result of their exposure
there are some who may suggest it's too
soon to do a remembrance
but i disagree i suspect that the
families of those
who have died would disagree and i
believe they would like
us to remember their lost ones
do it in a meaningful way not forget
and most importantly band together and
commit ourselves to whatever it takes
to overcome the current issues that face
us
with the raging virus
that has the capacity to take lives
it would be wonderful to announce
finally we're
finally ready to put an end to the
pandemic
but that isn't the case and we all know
that and as a result we know that the
twenty
eight hundred seventy three residents
who passed
is only part of the count we would hope
that the account would not get a whole
lot bigger
but we know that there will be others
who will succumb
so it requires of us a commitment to do
our part
the vaccine offers an opportunity
to do our part we hope that people
across this community will take it
seriously and if they have
already thought not to at least rethink
things
and consider it in any case we're
continuing to apply the resources that
are available to us
to get the vaccine out as fast as as it
is
provided to us and we've done about all
we can do in that regard
so there will be here
um an opportunity for us to remember
some of us don't know anybody personally
but this pandemic became very very
personal
personal to me when just a couple of
months ago
without even knowing that he he had been
hospitalized because of covid
i lost one of my dearest friends
who has been a friend of mine for
decades
it became very personal as i said and i
vowed then that i wasn't going to
question
things that i had questioned before it
was
it had really struck home with me that
anyone anyone because we do not know
what their chemistry is we do not know
what their dna would tell us
could in fact be numbered among those
who have passed
so we're remembering and we're
committing ourselves the 29 columns of
light
one for each 100 residents
stretching from here
in this room to the ceiling
and the uh and out the skylights to the
heavens
are a stark reminder of the enormity of
what has befallen us
and our commitment is that we not just
remember but that we
are motivated to act in a responsible
way
that will that may bring us to a place
where
we're really safe here that's our hope
may these people rest in peace and in
their memory ladies and gentlemen let us
now
illuminate this space as we have planned
to do
get the rest of my colleagues up so that
you could be part of this illumination
as we've all worked super hard to help
make our community better
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
you
[Music]
me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
hey
[Music]
my
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
um
[Music]
me
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
you